you
hey youtubers is charlie so Batman vs
Superman teaser aired during the Gotham
mid-season finale let's break it down
they're really like two options here one
this could be a dream sequence or two
this could actually be happening during
the movie there is this toy that they're
releasing called nightmare Batman where
he's wearing this outfit so that
definitely lends some evidence to the
dream sequence theory of this clip setup
is is that Superman looks like he is
captured Batman and unmasks him if you
remember your Christopher Reeve Superman
history there was an evil version of
superman that sneered like that i don't
necessarily think that that's what's
going on in this movie but he's making
the same face as when Lex Luthor touches
him in this other trailer so Luther
might have found a way to affect
Superman this could actually be
happening the dream sequence option is
that this could be Bruce Wayne just
manifesting his fears about the Man of
Steel because the setup for most of this
movie is is that he doesn't know what
Superman is going to do or what his
intentions are he's too dangerous he
caused all this damage someone has to
stop him before he goes bad the other
thing here is i think there's some dark
knight imagery here some frank miller
dark knight imagery these police in riot
gear with the Superman symbols if you
haven't read Frank Miller's Dark Knight
comic in a while there's a group called
the sons of Batman so after Batman
defeats the mutant leader a bunch of the
mutants start following him and he takes
them under his wing which is really
violent Batman fanatics that could be
kind of what's going on here visually
Zack Snyder was asked point blank at
comic-con is this movie in any way tied
to the Dark Knight's story Frank
Miller's Dark Knight story and he was
like no it is not there's some visual
references to that just paying to the
fact that Frank Miller's a genius for
the story of the actual movie is
something that he and Chris Tara just
can't came up with in a room by
themselves that's why I kind of think
they have the sons of Batman thing going
on here but because the movie is coming
out in March expect to get more in more
teasers like this as we get closer and
closer don't forget Deadpool's actually
coming out in February that's the first
big comic book movie that's coming then
Batman vs Superman then captain america
civil war but really like the other cool
thing to talk about in this is the look
of batman they're calling Ben Affleck's
Batman the Batman like Christian Bale's
Batman was referred to as the dark night
ben affleck is the batman as in th e
Batman Warner Brothers has been blowing
a whole lot of smoke about
this being like the most definitive
version of the characters they've ever
seen that's why they greenlit a new
trilogy with Ben Affleck I don't know if
that's them just trying to hype it up
because obviously I haven't seen the
movie yet but I do think it's going to
be really good even if it's not like the
greatest thing to ever hit cinema let me
know in the comments though here's the
big question is this actually happening
in the movie or is this like a Batman
hallucination the other question is as
if this really is happening in the movie
does it have something to do with Lex
Luthor synthesizing kryptonite because
he is definitely making some kryptonite
if you guys have it lying around be sure
to go watch superman 34 bearded evil
Superman who drinks in the middle of the
day day drinking Superman but I also
said I was going to do a giveaway so I'm
gonna do is give away gift certificate
for a batman-themed Funko you guys can
pick any one you want if you end up
winning it'll just be from amazon so I
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video just
like all the other giveaways that i do
if you guys that are big like flash
arrow fans I will be doing a new round
of that reverse flash ring giveaway
whenever I post my flash crossover video
tomorrow there's a crap ton of Awesome
DC stuff happening this week if you guys
didn't realize Frank Miller actually
wrote a new volume Dark Knight 3 they
released the first issue last week it's
called Dark Knight 3 master race you
find out why it's called master race at
the very end of that first issue so be
sure to check it out just in case you
guys haven't seen it you can click here
for the legends of tomorrow trailer all
the flash arrow videos that I've been
posting and you can click here for my
last Batman vs Superman trailer video
it's been a little while since we've had
a trailer thank you so much for watching
up everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight
you